today's session we got three talks for
you today the program is a little
shorter than yesterday because the the
second and the third talks will be 30
minutes as a reminder you just heard us
talk about the Q&A and so on so I'd like
if you have questions of content put
those questions in the Q&A don't send
them as a chat to the panelists and the
panelists will look at the Q&A questions
and they'll bring up during the talk or
after to talk and the panelist may also
you know ask Sarah question during a
talk anyhow
so that's the format and you have the
floor sir game right now okay thanks
Barbara
and ideally talking about classical
algorithms for quantum mean values I
hope you can hear me and see the slice
bread and this is a drawing for Chris
several people and David go set from IQ
here Alexander click and another kianak
from University of Munich my colleague
Ramiz masa and usual tank from Caltech
and so let me start with some motivation
so as you know quantum many-body systems
are hard to simulate on a classical
computer and this is primarily because
dimension of the Hilbert space grows
exponentially as we increase our system
size but sometimes we can avoid this
exponential scale and are using
traditional algorithms and these are
algorithms which are minimized expected
value of certain Colonel Tony nian over
some class of variational states that
depend on a small number of parameters
say polynomial in n and these days many
people are enthusiastic about a quantum
a variational algorithms such as
vqe and here the imagines that
variational states are defined by a
parameterized family of
quantum circuits and a quantum computer
is supposed to execute a state
preparation circuit perform a
measurement and then sent send
measurement outcomes to a classical
computer which estimates as a
variational energy and we might have to
repeat this step many times to find a
good variation of parameters that
minimize the energy and we're promising
ideas how to apply this method to
quantum chemistry or material science
simulations as well as classical
optimization and I guess the main
selling point of our BQE is they don't
need high fidelity quantum gates in a
certain sense between is in a certain
sense Vickie is robust against
systematic unitary errors and there are
ideas how to mitigate random errors such
as the polarizing noise and given all
this enthusiasm I think it's important
that we clearly understand limitations
of this method and first we have
hardware limitations our quantum
circuits what we can implement reliably
on near John devices I likely took that
small depth and qubit connectivity is
likely to be limited say we can only do
say nearest neighbor gates on a
two-dimensional array of qubits but even
if you have our fault tolerant universal
quantum computer we might have to worry
about algorithmic limitations so somehow
we have to minimize variational energy
over circuit parameters and this is our
final nonlinear optimization problem and
there are reasons to believe that it's
generally non tractable say if you use
gradient-based optimizer
then that would be a button plateau
effect then a gradient of the objective
function becomes exponentially small and
yes my question is whether quantum
variational algorithms can can beat
classical algorithms for some problem in
spite of all these limitations and let
me first talk about simulation of
quantum systems say we start from some
Hamiltonian describing a system of
electrons this could be a molecule this
fixed position of a new clay and then R
be expressed as a kernel Tony on in the
second quantized picture by picking some
set of orbitals now each term in the
Hamiltonian is expressed in terms of a
thermionic a creation annihilation
operators and then the muppets to a
qubit Hamiltonian for example using
Jordan beginner our transformation now
each term in the final cubed Hamiltonian
is attends a product of single qubit
power operators XY and Z and all these
steps can be done efficiently on a
classical computer so now comes the
quantum part of BQE so we prepare some
variational State outside a measure
expected value of of our Hamiltonian and
by linearity it suffices to measure
expected value of each individual powder
and forward we just need to measure each
individual qubit in the eigen basis of
our powder X or Y or Z and then
classically compute the product of
measured outcomes so the upshot is that
the only quantum part of the QE
algorithm is preparing
variational state and are measuring
expected
of some tensor product observable and
what we try to do is to somehow isolate
this step and understand its
computational complexity and this leads
to a quantum mean value problem defined
here so yes so we are given some load F
quantum circuit you action on until
dates and some are observable PN which
has tensor product of single qubit
observables this could be a power
operator but we don't have to be and the
problem is to approximate expected value
of this observable on the output state
of view these are some specified
precision are epsilon and yes so the
question is do we really need a quantum
computer R to solve this problem and how
they'll can be do classically so yes so
this table shows a runtime of a
classical algorithm but souls are
quantum in value problem the runtime
depends on our circuit depth and cubed
connectivity and here I wonder consider
the constant depth and connectivity is
is a two-dimensional or
three-dimensional Lakers so in the 2d
case our algorithm has a runtime are
linear in the number of qubits and
pieces are essentially optimal because
we need linear time just to examine each
gate in the circuit and there is also
inverse polynomial dependence on
precision Epsilon and our foe comparison
are the best previously known algorithm
wishes attention evoke a contraction by
markovin shield as runtime exponential
in a square root of n but a tensor
network contraction is essentially exact
algorithm
so there is no dependence on excellent
then in the three-dimensional case our
algorithm has exponential runtime but
exponent is slightly better than what
you get from our tensor network our
contraction year so the upshot is what
if we hope to achieve
quantum advantage then we should somehow
improve qubit connectivity it should be
better than two-dimensional lattice or
the certain proof circuit depth so we
need say maybe a logarithmic or linear
circuit depth and for general constant
depth circuits that are not
geometrically local our algorithm has
runtime exponential in square root of M
but it is one important period they can
only compute the magnitude of quantum in
value so the mean value can be either
positive or negative but our algorithm
cannot determine the sign okay can I ask
a brief question so the dependence on
the concepts you are not giving here
right you need dependence on the taps
you're not giving here which will
probably be pretty bad it's exponential
in our depth squared oh okay yeah okay
so you're even paying Thanks yes
questions yeah I'm a question so can't
you add dummy variables so that you you
boost the number by a certain amount and
then depending upon whether the answer
was negative or positive you know you
see the change and know what sign was
yes you can do something like a smoke
test to determine the sign but then as
the circuit depth becomes super constant
so they don't know how to squeeze swap
test and
than that
there are more questions at this point
okay continue Sergey okay yes so let me
sketch very briefly how the algorithm
works in the simplest case which is
constant depth are 2d and the idea is to
express a quantum mean value as inner
product between two quantum states
so I once I - what are computationally
tractable in a certain sense and what I
mean by that is that we can easily
conclude amplitudes of say one cycle in
the standard basis and we can
efficiently example probability
distributions defined by epsilon and
cycle and that is a very nice algorithm
are proposed by London anest that
approximates inner products between
computationally tractable states for
example it is known that matrix product
states with a small bond dimension are
computationally tractable and wishes
through regardless of how the order
qubits
and I should emphasize that this
algorithm is approximate one and it
achieves a small additive error and
computing say in a product exactly or
this a small multiplicative error is
much more difficult problem which is a
sharp D hat
even if they talk about amputation and
attractable States and this algorithm is
basically a Monte Carlo approach so you
can express as a inner product you can
use this identity to express the inner
product as mean value of certain
function f of X which is efficiently
computable always certain probability
distribution are P of X which is easier
to sample and this function f of X can
take very large values but it happens
that it's variance is about it by 1 and
then what we can do is to generate
sufficiently many samples from this
distribution RT of X and compute a
empirical mean value and by turboshaft
and equality the approximation error
scales like 1 over square root of the
number of samples so this is the idea of
London last algorithm and now let's come
back to quantum mean values so I can see
the two dimensional lattice each site of
the latest is a qubit and our we have
constantly observed it you that includes
only our nearest neighbor our two qubit
gates as shown here and such circuits
have certain local features but we can
exploit for example if you take a single
qubit observable acting
some qubit J and we conjugated by by
such circuit you they get some local
operator which has support in a light
corn of radios proportional to the
circuit depth
so if depth is constant the light cone
has constant radius and I let me call
this local or director addressed
observable so this is the formal
definition and the first step is to
compute this addressed observable for
for each qubit and this can be done
efficiently because we can restrict the
circuit on to a light cone and a light
cone has constant size so then the
quantum mean value can be expressed
using this equation so the thefts are a
product of all dressed observables and
when we compute mean we do this respect
to all 0 state and order in this product
does not matter because because the rest
observables are pairwise commute then
the second step doesn't really do
innocent we just course the reigns of
artists such that are any dressed
observable X on a 2 by 2 block of sites
in the coarse-grained our latest and now
each site of the lattice is acute this
local dimension capital D which is
exponential in the circuit depth R
squared but if the circuit has constant
depth then our local dimension is
constant yes so this is just a summary
of what we have achieved so far and then
comes the interesting step so I want to
express the quantum mean value as the
inner product between two matrix product
states and
so this picture illustrates how it works
so so we partitions the lattice into
horizontal strips and they will be two
different partitions a and a partition B
and then we define a state of say a by
taking all zero state and then apply a
product of all dressed observables that
are fully contained in some strip in the
partition a and so here I show some
examples of such observables and then we
define the steps I be similarly using
partition B and the fact that addressed
observables pairwise commute means let
say a MC be a matrix product states with
a small bond dimension so it's like
applying constant F 1 dimensional
circuit this pairwise commuting gates
and such circuit cannot generate much
entanglement so so this bond dimension
is there if each site of the lattice is
a QD to this local dimension capital D
then the bond dimension is at most
capital d squared which which is bounded
by a constant yes
Anton are basically by construction this
quantum mean value is the inner product
between up side a and side B but it is
in the middle that has some permutation
of qubits and beneath this permutation
because say a and ab CB i defined for
two different linear order of qubits so
to define a matrix product state we must
choose some linear order of qubits and
here may be using two different Aurora's
yes and finally we as I said
matrix product states are
computationally tractable for any auto
qubits
so we can estimate as a inner product by
wantonness algorithm and in the
three-dimensional case algorithm is only
slightly more complicated but I'm not
going to discuss it okay so next I want
to talk about something different and
misses a quantum approximate
optimization algorithm proposed by a
farcical stone and Woodman and here the
goal is to maximize a classical cost
function but depends on n binary
variables and for concreteness let me
talk about Isaac type cost function so
we have some graph G with n vertices and
Isaac variables leaf at beauticians of
the graph and we have interactions
between nearest neighbor variables and
here so a few AOA consists of three
steps so first the promote classical
cost function to a quantum channel tone
e'en so basically it has values of the
cost function on the diagonal and all of
diagonal matrix elements are 0 then we
maximize expected energy of this
Hamiltonian over a suitable a class of
variational States but depend on a few
parameters and finally we take the
optimal variational state measure each
field it and obtain a classical solution
and as I mean where you know if you look
at the mean value of classical cost
function on this solution it coincides
with the quantum mean video and so far
here to proposed the following a
variational States so we initialize each
qubit in the plus state
and suddenly apply a plantain silicate
wet alternates between two types of
layers each a blue layer applies unitary
time evolution under the cost function
and cost functional tone Ian and each
red layer is unitary evolution and a
simple candle tone Ian which is sum of
single qubit X operators so this is like
transverse transverse field operator and
each layer comes with variational
parameter gamma J or beta J which is the
evolution time and yes so so this a
vital variational state has a level deal
if this quantum circuit contains at P
blue layers and P red layers and so I
guess the main motivation from his
answers is adiabatic quantum computation
that slowly interpolates between a cost
functional tone Ian and a transverse
magnetic field a Newtonian so in salina
tension level D is very large say
polynomial in n QA or a can be viewed as
an authorized version of adiabatic
quantum computation but there are
reasons to keep as a level P as small as
possible and this this comes from his
algorithmic and hardware limitations
which I mentioned in the beginning
somehow they must be able to minimize
variational energy over this parameters
beta and gamma and which is very hard
optimization problem and we must be able
to implement this variational circuit
and the depth of this circuit is roughly
linear in the level P so the question is
can low level a QA or a are bit
classical optimization algorithms for
some problem
and unfortunately as answer is negative
it was shown by a Hastings web
approximation Kershaw achieved by level
1 to AOA is inferior to what can be done
with classical local classical
optimization algorithms at least for
bounded degree graphs and in our paper
we showed that level P a this any
constant level P R is inferior to
classical approximation algorithms based
on our SDP relaxations and can I ask you
a question Sergei the QA or a here
you're not assuming any spatial locality
right no yeah any other questions yeah
are there other questions
yeah if I may just one quick question so
for the lower bounds for the queue away
unbound degree wraps
the worst case is pork you away and GW
are not gonna be the same right so can
there be a subclass of boundary grad
degree graphs where a queue away still
beats GW oh yeah I don't really know I
wouldn't be surprised if one can find
such examples but I have not tried to do
that yo gates yes so if you are
interested please come to a talk by
Robert later today and he will describe
this result in details and basically
what we try to do is to try to overcome
these limitations are ambitious based on
a new idea which we call variable
elimination so we what we are trying to
do is to use a QA or a as a subroutine
in a classical optimization algorithm so
let me explain how it works yes so first
we are the runs a standard a QA or a
decent fix level P and again I'm
considering I think type our cost
function so then we find optimal
parameters beta and gamma prepare
optimal variational state and compute
with quantum mean values so for each
pair of qubits we compute mean values of
poly is easy observable and somehow it
quantifies correlations between
variables and then we identify a pair of
variable switches a maximally correlated
in the sense that the magnitude of this
quantum mean value is the maximum and
okay so that is a question related to
this simulation of two dimensional
constant depth circuits how general is
partitioned into two by two block south
sides but surkhi you can also take this
question afterwards if you want if
you're an amount of flow it's okay maybe
it would be better easier yes so they
look at Miss maximally correlated pair
of variables and we on the impose a
parity constraint so if the variables
are positively correlated we require
which B equals a and if the negatively
correlated we require that B equals
minus a and then we examine each John in
the cost function that includes variable
B and replace it by plus minus a so this
way we obtain a new eyes and type cost
function that depends only on n minus 1
our variable and then the idea is to
apply this variable elimination are many
times such that at each step we
eliminate one variable and we stop them
the final problem is so small that we
can solve it by a brute force so let me
illustrate this by an example say
suppose we start from isin model defined
on a graph these five notices they're on
standard quue defined maximally
correlated player of enables say 2 & 3
then be imposed parity constraint and
eliminate variable three now with
epigraph is only a forged is's durán
standard q oa5 maximally correlated
player we eliminate
variable for and now
can solve this small instance by brute
force and assign a value plus minus one
to each variable and finally we assign a
value to all variables that have been
eliminated and for that we just be
traced back political strains which have
been imposed and so here I show how this
works are in practice and I'm
considering isin random bond ISIL model
defined on complete graph this 150 sees
and so yes all this plot shows
approximation a ratio achieved by
different algorithms the worst-case
sorry the best cases approximation ratio
one the worst cases zero and you can see
that recursive q AOE outperforms the
standard kill we and for comparison i
also show performance of SDP relaxation
algorithm and yes so the performance of
our QE is comparable to what we get from
SDP a relaxation which is essentially
the best known classical algorithm or I
should say the best known to us so the
recursive Toa way looks looks promising
and then so they also looked at a
different optimization problem which is
called marks free card and this is
basically optimization version of graph
coloring graphs recurrent problem so now
each vertex of a graph is a variable but
okay we are trying to assign a color to
each vertex of a graph in this case
there are only three colors or 0 1 2 and
the cost function is the number of edges
but have endpoints of different colors
and our goal is to approximate the
maximum of this cost function and for
example if the big vertex coloring at
random we can achieve approximation
ratio at least 2/3 and the best known
classical algorithm it's also based on
SDP relaxation method achieves
approximation ratio roughly 83% and so
one can easily generalize QA or a and
variable elimination method from cubits
to curious so basically one just need to
replace Apollo operators X and Z by
generalized power operators at computers
and so we did numerical simulation of
level 1 QA or a and it's recursive
version for a randomly generated problem
instances so here we consider graphs
with 50 beauty C's and we have sort of a
planted solution such that all these
graphs are 3 colorable so the maximum
cost function is just the number of
edges in the graph and so again here the
plot shows comparison between standard
recursive level 1 Q AOA and classical s
as the P relaxation method but this
comparison is not quite fair because
in the case of SDP we are talking about
worst-case approximation ratio and in
the case of
rpoe we talk about average case
approximation ratio but nevertheless you
can see what the recursive accurate way
performs quite well can I ask you a
question the business - so how do you do
these simulations this is just you
classically simulate this these
algorithms okay actually this is my next
slide
yes so the reason why we're on the
looked at level 1 queue AOA is because
we know how to simulate it numerically
for very large systems like 100 cubits
but this also means that there is no
quantum advantage if we can simulate
quantum algorithm classically it's not
very useful and basically the only
quantum step of our to AOA algorithm is
computing this quantum mean values for
apologies observables and theories it
happens whether it is efficient the
polynomial time classical algorithm whet
our computes such mean values and it was
proposed by Venkat all in this paper and
let me describe a slightly more general
version of this algorithm that works not
only for two dates but for two days of
constant dimension and I will use some
pictorial notation so this red box
denotes a single qubit excitation so it
just means some unitary operator which
is diagonal in the eigen basis of power
X and this blue dashed line denotes
diagonal to qubit two qubit gate so then
level 1 variational states are have this
form so be initialized each qubit and
plus
apply
layer of too cute bayano gates and then
apply a layer of ex rotations
and the quantum are say they want to
compute mean value of some two qubit
observable which acts on Fugit one and
two so yes so basically we have to
evaluate with a quantum circuit and yes
so the first think we can do is to
cancel all gates but do not touch are
queued at one and two because such gate
come in conjugate pairs so then we can
we can examine all gates action only on
queued at 1 and Q 2 and apply all these
gates to the observable so this gives
some a modified observable or tilde and
we can efficiently compute because a
tilde because basically we just need to
evaluate with a small sub circuit and
then so I want to change the order of 2
cubed gates such that accurate 1 & 2 are
sequentially coupled to all remaining
cuties so in this example the first
couple than two curiously and then we
couple them to acute at 4 and somehow
each time via a couple we apply one of
these couplings this can be described by
a quantum are channel which is shown
here so this this channel takes as input
two qubits brings in ancillary cubed
prepared in maximally mixed state then
applies a pair of two qubit unitary
gates and then projects as ancillary
cuted onto a plus state and because we
we are doing couplings are sequentially
it means where essentially we have to
simulate a pro
of roughly N quantum channels of this
form and then compute a suitable matrix
element and because these channels act
on two qubits of constant dimension we
can compute such a product classically
in linear time yes so this gives
classical algorithm for computing
quantum in values for level 1 q April
8th and yes as I said it means that
there is no hope for a quantum advantage
and perhaps we should look at higher
levels of IQ AOA and are in the rest of
the talk I will describe what happens
for level 2 so again they want to
compute mean value of some two qubit
observable on level 2 variational State
and so these are our results ok I forgot
to say that we we assume that our cost
function is defined on some interaction
graph it means that we can only apply to
Q debt gates on nearest neighbor
vertices on the interaction graph and
the run time of our algorithm depends on
this interaction graph for general
graphs as a run time is exponential but
it's only 2 2 n over 2 and for
comparisons brute force simulation
algorithm would at runtime roughly 2 to
the N so we have a sort of square root
speed-up and in the special case then
interaction graph is planar our
algorithm has polynomial run time and
somehow you could say that Issac model
on planar graphs is not very interesting
because it can be solved exactly but our
algorithm
so votes for generalized Iceland model
I've been very pleased cubits by huges
with a constant dimension yoga can ask
so you're saying if the interaction grab
is three-dimensional so you still have a
polynomial Albert start with your son
not know so they only have polynomial
algorithm for planar graphs later this
variant non planar yeah yes so let me
try to sketch how this algorithm works
and yes so I apologize for this awkward
notations so I divide the circuit into
bill players and she leaves believes
ordinate glued single qubit X rotations
and I see layers on the include two
qubit diagonal gates and first we
perform some simple manipulations to
simplify this quantum circuit so first
we conjugate observable by the in a pair
of beliefs and this gives some modified
to to deter observe herbal or tilde then
we reapply in a pair of C layers as
before we can cancel all two cured gates
but do not touch culet one or two and
then using the fact that all these gates
are diagonal one can show that this
middle part of the circuit becomes a
linear combination of tensor product
observables and this linear combination
has only a constant number of terms and
this is not entirely obvious but let me
skip the proof so from now on I focus on
one single term in this linear
combination so this I think in the
middle is just a tensor product
observable or
you can also think of it as a product of
single qubit unitary gates then the
apply in a pair of beliefs so here we
only have local gates so we get some
modified tensor product observable Patil
de and the last step is to express this
quantum mean value as the inner product
between some computationally tractable
states so I want to play the same game
as before and so first we need to define
these two states so i 1m situ and yeah
so I look at each single qubit gate in
this middle part and assign sorry I
assign each of these gates either to the
left part or to the right part of the
circuit such that there are exactly n
over 2 gates on the left and an over two
gates on the right and then the left
part of the circuit defines some state
Taiwan as the right part defines some
state situ and the quantum mean value is
just inner product between Taiwan and up
situ now so why I say what which states
are computationally tractable
well I claim that we can compute any
amplitude of these states are in time
roughly 2 to + / 2 so we are not
tractable computationally tractable in
proneural sense but they have some
non-trivial they have some structure and
so on this picture I consider states i1
as example suppose we want to compute
the amplitude of psy one on some basis
vector like 0 1 1 0 then
[Music]
every every two cubits diagonal gate but
touches a qubit initialized in zero or
one state can be removed because such
gate cannot basically such gate can be
replaced by a single qubit single Q the
diagonal gates it cannot create any
entanglement so it means that somehow we
can essentially ignore one half of all
qubits because they cannot be entangled
and we have to simulate only and over
two qubits and this can be done by a say
state vector simulation or any other
algorithm and the same is true for the
states I 2 and then if you use one the
nest algorithm that I showed you in the
beginning the runtime becomes 2 2 + /
true but now suppose our interaction
graph is not general but it's a planar
graph and then somehow we have a
complete freedom in how we choose a
partition of qubits to define these 2
States Taiwan and outside - and they can
ask if we can pick a good partition of
qubits such that Taiwan am situ are
become a weekly internal state and so I
don't need this graph theoretic result
proved by a divorce and others and it
says what if you give me any planar
graph I can divide the set of vertices
into two subsets b1 and b2 such that sub
graphs are induced by b1 and b2 have
very small attributes trivets at most
are too
for example subgraph okay
yes Oh on this picture illustrates how
to construct with subsets so we are we
partition vertices of a planar graph
into concentric layers started from the
outer phase of the graph and mugen
towards the center and then every edge
of the graph is a connects to the dishes
at the same layer or connects a pair of
your dishes at two consecutive layers
and then we choose subject v1 to include
all say all odd layers so then the sub
graphene used by v1 only include edges
that connect our players of vertices in
v1 and this sub graph is basically a
union of path graphs and cycle graphs or
more generally we may have outer planar
graphs and the same clue is for sub
graph induced by a subset a B - and now
suppose again we want to compute some
amplitude of these states i won
and so if you look at some two qubit
gate but touches a qubit in the subset
v2 such gate disappears because this
qubit is projected onto zero or one
state so it means that are the only two
qubit gates which can potentially create
entanglement are those associated with
edges of this sub graph induced by v1
and because here so this means with
amplitudes of epsilon are defined by a
tensor
Network defined on these graphs with
very small three bits and we can compute
amplitudes of say one by our contract
increased attention at work using the
standard algorithm by Markov and she and
of course the same is true for the state
outside - yes so just to summarize the
obtain a polynomial time a classical
algorithm for approximating quantum in
various of few qubit observables for
level two QA q a or a states defined on
planar graphs and somehow a nice
property of variable elimination and
recursive q a or e is what it preserves
up linearity so say if we have a pair of
nearest neighbor variables a and B and
we eliminate variable B it it means that
we contract an H of the graph connecting
a and B and H contraction maps planar
graphs to our planar graphs so if we
start from a planar graph then each step
of recursive to AoE generates a planar
graph so so we can use this algorithm to
do classical simulation of level two are
two a or a for cost function for any
cost function defined on planar graph
yes and this is pretty much all I said
to say here so there are some
interesting open problems it is it would
be very interesting to establish some
hardness results for approximating a
quantum mean values say in the case of
load F quantum circuits or
low-level QA or a States and it would be
nice to establish some attagirls bounds
on the performance of our QA or a and
maybe consider some more general
strategies for variable elimination yes
and thank you for attention
Hey Thank You Sergey for a very nice
talk sure there are many questions I'm
looking at fari has a question here I
don't know if that now can speak up so I
tried to change him ed can you say
something I think it's microphone is
turned off but otherwise online can I be
heard yes yeah okay Sergei another
beautiful talk from you thank you so
much hi hi I didn't want to say
something about P equals 1 and P equals
2 QA away I mean it's really not
terribly surprising that it's very low
depth the algorithm will not work well
because if you look at the light-cone or
if you look at the cost function which
is the sum of terms and then you
conjugate the terms with the unitary
operator that involves the evolution if
you're an abounded degree graph the
number of qubits that each term seeds is
far fewer than all the qubits and we
always knew that you would have to have
that light cone extent to the whole
graph in order for there to be the
possibility about with mixed success and
I think Sergey is result which with his
collaborators which will be discussed
later today is an example of that and I
have a recent paper with Kumar naka got
men showing that all from maximum
independence at if the depth is less
than a constant times log and that the
QA away will fail on typical instances
randomly generated but once the depth is
log n you know then you see the whole
graph and
no indication the algorithm will fail
and I think you know like this luck I
think we need to move beyond constant
depth and just real but blocking may be
enough and I think we really need to
stop focusing on that and in turn
practical terms if you look at the paper
by Sergei and his collaborators it's
also a log and resolved but at two
million cubits it only shows the
algorithm fails the people's one and I
think we should be cognizant to that
that you know showing and our results
only show the algorithm fails the people
set of a six at a million cubits on
three regular graphs and you know log in
is very forgiving because you know
million cubits logarithm is not very
much and we may have a disk device where
log n is easy to achieve so I think we
really need to get our wrap our heads
around that that you know constant that
this it's really interesting and it's
nice to show things but you know you
gotta go to log n yeah I mean I
absolutely agree but one comment is what
we should distinguish between a constant
depth and a constant level of QA OE
because if you look at this recursive
algorithm that I described yeah it's
basically even if you start from degree
free graph each a variable elimination
step at adds more edges to the graph so
the degree of the graph would would grow
and you quickly end up with dense graph
so each qubit can see any other qubit
okay even for level one version of the
algorithm okay always like what option
is to increase as a depth or another
option used to look at a recursive
version of the algorithm right or else
the other thing to do is to look at
graphs which you complete and we wrote a
paper on sherry - Patrick model where
you have a complete
wrap it up equals one you see the whole
graph and we have nice results on that I
wish we could continue this discussion
but and maybe if other people have
questions to share again I can put them
in the Q&A but we'll also have a few
minute break before we have the next
stock let's thank Sergey again